[Applause]
it's a beautiful day to be alive uncle
Joey hey you like where the [ __ ] you
been I've been busy [ __ ] I'd bawl
fest right in my family planes you know
yeah now the [ __ ] there's no jujitsu
cause I'm [ __ ] Stuart my [ __ ]
Vertigo's back but that ain't gonna stop
uncle Joey's I'm sayin the reefer must
[ __ ] go on we got some tremendous
reefer today we still got this leftover
presidential I've been holding on to it
because it's that [ __ ] special and I
got this [ __ ] from perennial that's been
killing me all week two blue [ __ ]
cookies buddy enough with the
chitty-chat uncle Joey sparked that
[ __ ] shoot that poison arrow
through his heart [ __ ] it's good to see
you [ __ ] I'm in Phoenix tonight
I'm at the Comedy Store belly room
Tuesday night 8 o'clock doing [ __ ]
special hour front that down in Columbus
Ohio this week and so it hasn't stopped
we got a podcast tomorrow night at 8:00
I'm gonna do jet to tomorrow and all
this [ __ ] with vertigo you understand me
and we taught my driving a little busy
and [ __ ] when I sit down I get up which
means I'm getting on you know something
wrong my [ __ ] is but that's why we're
here the refill take care everything
look at that tremendous I'm balling the
vertical out of my earlobes when I read
[ __ ] hit you probably sitting there
watching football with your friends in
the onion dip man our Lipton and [ __ ]
you're gonna be farting like a [ __ ]
horse tonight but who gives a [ __ ] you
having a good time that's what the
Lord's Day is all about sit with your
friends and go on Jesus Christ I need a
new set of [ __ ] bums to hang out with
now you go eat you put your family you
take a walk he go to the [ __ ] Park
I'm waiting for these to your drools to
get back from church so I can [ __ ]
take the baby for a little stroll before
I have to get on my late afternoon
flight to [ __ ] Phoenix you got 13
days to the special [ __ ] and I got
Beyonce I'm prepared because of you guys
your [ __ ] kept me in check
making me smoke weed and [ __ ] go deep
look into the murky waters the
underworld you find jokes down there
from time to time let's do a [ __ ] I'm
just presidential get the party started
right I smoked these things like nothing
there's no [ __ ] pipe it to fill it to
the top
Oh two [ __ ] heads it's [ __ ]
crashed a nice little smoothly this
morning I had my protein shake
I want to picked up my supply of reefer
for the week it's in the cards Ryan
getting brittle as we [ __ ] speak
and now I'm just getting prepared for
another ho-hum week of [ __ ] kicking
ass and taking names you understand me
gulps I'm with a little light exercise
today see if I don't be [ __ ] dizzy
while I'm doing subs last time I did a
[ __ ] sit up on that vertigo was a
[ __ ] nightmare and trust me nobody
needs sit-ups more than [ __ ] me I'm a
stretch a little bit that little [ __ ]
blood gum a little sweat going by the
time the girls get back I'd do a little
packing and bam that we got the
afternoon with the [ __ ] ladies I
still [ __ ] him did my dad thing and
now I go pick up a [ __ ] envelope
who's better than me that's the most
important thing listen I got rid of one
[ __ ] family cuz I acted like an
[ __ ] I'm keeping this one dawg I'm
keeping this one good so I do what I
have to do you go jump around hang out
with your buddies I'm keeping my [ __ ]
family
besides that man I love you
[ __ ] I'm working on this
special because of you I want you to put
this special number is my [ __ ] uncle
Joey [ __ ] to be proud yeah he
was in prison yeah he hacked Don J was a
[ __ ] yeah he quit high school yeah his
parents died have a look he didn't give
a [ __ ] it's the people that keep that on
the back well it happened I had a big
[ __ ] challenge I either had a [ __ ]
choose my career and my life and then
end up in jail well staying more than
your persecuted be a [ __ ] bad they
didn't want me to be a dad
I did this thing you know what 20 is
[ __ ] later I showed up with a
specially validated my son hey she
doesn't want me to be a dad no things
happen to [ __ ]
we [ __ ] up I set out to do the goal
and I hit it and now they got on a son
right thickness sometimes you gotta
break some [ __ ] eggshells I can make
enough don't say Joey what's with the
[ __ ] he'd beat spot that goat
[ __ ]
let's do it
as [ __ ] the bird makes Melissa beaver
get Noah chatty gotta smack me twice the
dog in 30 times to shut up
[ __ ] I'm starting to hear yes
roundabout cannelli like the stereo but
that's it that's that guys you know I
love you I'm here for you God suckers
will you're making it together they
can't stop us it's Sunday
they won't listen these [ __ ]
couldn't stop me if they wanted to even
if they put a frame if they tried to set
me up even if I gave up they still
couldn't follow me that's the attitude
even if I give up they still can't
[ __ ] what do you think we got a
little bit left I don't give a [ __ ]
about the Vikings I'm talking about
[ __ ] life getting stormed what we're
gonna do the takeover everybody's
worried about Hillary you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
listen don't matter it's you that's got
to get up every morning it's you that's
gonna [ __ ] snap [ __ ] to get
where you want to be who gives a [ __ ]
well it's us gotta learn how to see the
devil I just had my primal pokey shake
vanilla coconut I'm full now I'm stoked
I'm happy you guys join me my little
Sunday morning family to get stoned and
see the devil I love you [ __ ] you
know I do don't forget I need your
Tuesday night eight o'clock the belly
room $15 tickets from doing the hole
with Ted and we go back to the drawing
board on Wednesday morning then I go to
Columbus Thursday Friday Saturday bone
we do what we do we go back to the paper
and I got the Comedy Store again on the
11th we do what we do and then we had
what Chicago no looking back
I try to do the best job I can for you
[ __ ] and that's it stay black
stay stomped hug your mother hug the
[ __ ] dog and I'll see you [ __ ]
tomorrow
[Music]